i know a lot of you who watch
my channel are watching kind of for the
video editing stuff and sometimes people
ask what's a really simple
video editor and i found one that i just
want to share with you
and it's animotocon now this might be
one of the best if you're just doing
simple stuff for things like um well
youtube
instagram igtv and facebook and
in general just kind of sharing little
videos with your friends on social media
platforms because
it's just so straightforward and it has
a lot of little neat features
so um i'm going to we're just going to
go over here
i don't think we're going to we're
probably not going to do much of a
tutorial but
i don't think it's really necessary
because everything is just so simple
with this editor but i at least want to
make everyone aware of it and just kind
of show you the overview of everything
it can do so it can record your screen
because that's
the first thing a lot of people are
going to ask but also
you can you just well let's just walk
through this you can add a video
you edit it and you share and you render
it but of course it's a little more than
that
this doesn't really uh this is the front
page so
it basically just kind of sells it on
being really simple and it really is
but it can do actually quite a bit it's
got some built-in transitions you can do
all the splitting and cutting and making
sure your videos
uh just exactly how you want it it also
has a feature where you can add a
voiceover
right within the editor so that seems
pretty cool and of course they got a
bunch of effects and filters because
everybody loves those
and you can of course add text and gifs
pretty easily
just pop them right in there and uh
here's a
bunch more features there are more than
this but as you can see you can adjust
the color change the video speed
whatever video size you want so you can
get in any format you want for whether
you want it
tall wide whatever and there also is a
green screen effect
so if you have a green screen and you
want to do some fancy stuff you can pop
that right in here as well
we have rotating transforming background
music
blur of the video mute you can do a
slideshow
you know crop fade in fade out motion
video stabilization
and i guess that's pretty good rating
too so can't really go
wrong with that okay now i'm gonna pop
out of this screen okay there's some of
the formats
like uh the snapchat instagram and tick
tock format there
and we got a six by 16 by nine which is
pretty standard for youtube
vimeo all the big video sites and then
we get that just a square image too
which might be good for i guess it's
showing facebook and instagram here too
so
this is free completely free although
there are some ads within it once you
get going
all right so let's take a look at some
other blurbs about it
i've got a whole list of things here
that i might have missed
so it has over 40 special effects 40
video transitions
i think we already talked about most
this just from their front page but i
think there's a few others
custom watermarks let's see here
you can do reverse i think the voiceover
thing is pretty cool
it looks like i might just have some of
these twice but okay yeah that that's
basically it so here it is and uh
you can get it of course from the
website but also if you're on windows 10
you can just grab it right from the
microsoft store
and install it right from there
and it does say that it's also for your
mobile device so there is
if i understand this right a mobile
version of this a lot of people just
like to do everything with their phones
for
social media so that seems like it's
possible
so pretty cool so when you first launch
it this is what it looks like and we're
just going to kind of pop in here and
play around a little bit and then
we'll call it a video so here's the
first launch of it
and it's going to give us a little tour
create amazing video so we can kind of
get an idea of what this is going to
look like
you can see they got these nice bars
and it looks like it might only be one
video here but i'm pretty sure you can
do more than that
and they have pretty simplistic little
menus here they don't really overwhelm
you with too much
i know a lot of the video tutorials i do
of for like blender
and resolve and stuff there's just an
overwhelming amount of stuff and that
might be just way too much if you're
just getting started
it's really nice to start with these
more simple editors
because you can get an idea of what's
possible without having to dive through
a bunch of technical details it just
gives you the most common things
there's filters there background music
and as you can see there
there are some different little tracks
here so you can
have some different tracks it looks like
and even animate your overlays pretty
cool so
of course this is all stuff you can do
with the big editors but you have to get
really meticulous about it looks like
this just kind of does it for you
when you go to render you just pick what
you want you pick your
resolution frames per second your bit
rate
and that way you can get the quality and
size you want so let's pop
right in here and here is the front page
and it looks like it's just telling me
even right here that it wants me to
update
this is a fresh install of windows so
it's still doing some updates
but it looks like it is developed well
enough to even be able to
detect that so that is pretty cool
and i'm going to go ahead and just make
this full screen so we can see
everything here
it looks like we got the ability to open
a new project here
or open project or new and there's some
quick tools here if you just want to do
something really quick so i guess
i'm just going to click new project and
go with
uh we'll go with empty project here
gives us a name
looks like we picked and pick an aspect
ratio i'm going to do widescreen for now
and it wants us to pick a place to save
it i'm just going to leave it where it
is by default there
but as you can see there's a whole bunch
of different options for
your project and yeah already so far
this is just super simple
so someone x out of this thing is
telling me i need to upgrade windows
don't worry i will eventually
so we do have to add a video or photo
clip and it looks like we'll be able to
start
editing now i'm pretty sure most of you
could probably figure this out pretty
well
looks like they got undo and go forward
a little settings button here
so you can change things and up here
they've got a little hamburger menu
and there's not a whole lot here looks
like they got a save
now i don't think i have a whole lot of
video clips let me see if i can pull one
in
okay so i'm just going to click add
video or photo clips here
it looks like you can do color giphy or
take a photo or video so you can even
use your cam probably there
or maybe it even offers to record your
screen i'm not sure
no it looks like it's popping up my cam
but my cam's being used by my other
recording software so it doesn't like
that let's do add
video or photo and i'm just going to go
to this drive go to my recordings
it looks like i've got maybe something
here of a little uh
i like to do games in a lot of these
cases because a lot of color
so i'll just click this little magic
match here it looks like it
shows in pretty low quality i recorded
this in way higher quality so that just
might be
the way it's showing but let's just take
a look and see what we got here
preview quality okay so we're looking at
the preview quality
it looks like it does lower this it's
probably so it can be a little fast you
know if it did this at the highest
quality you'd probably be really lagging
while you're editing
but it looks like it does give us some
options here to change
or so we can see what the ratio
of the video is in its final form here
so if we wanted to do one for
tablet or whatever yeah you guys get the
picture there okay so we got our little
clip here
it says click on clip to edit so we
click on here
and it looks like we can do all sorts of
stuff too let's just click on trim
it's pretty common thing and uh okay and
then we
let's click out of that so it looks like
we can just scroll along here and kind
of get the
picture here and it looks like it says
made with emoticon okay so it is going
to give us a watermark it looks like
and we do have to pay to get rid of that
watermark so though
uh that disappoints me a little bit
but it looks like you can i wonder if
you can get around that at all
and that doesn't look like we're gonna
be able to get around that but that
might not bother some people if you're
just doing a quick clip
for like a thing but if you want to do
if you want it to look more professional
you're probably going to want to get rid
of that by
by doing the paid thing so yeah they
really do try to get you there it is
free to use but
uh you're going to get that watermark
unless you pay
what was it 6.99 or move
waterpark or unlock all
so i see so yeah i guess just seven
bucks so you can
get rid of that watermark forever and
you can get better output so it looks
like it is going to limit our output
and yeah
it is what it is guys 16 bucks unlocks
everything
i guess it might be worth it if you find
it super simple it does look
way more simple than the video editing
stuff i
use so you know based on the amount of
time it might save you if you're really
stuck on those big ones
it could be worth it it's up to you of
course you make that call i'm not going
to tell you what to buy
i'm just kind of showing you what's out
there let's just look at these effects
here and see what we can get
all kinds of effects
there's quite a few here
well there's some weird mirrors and
stuff all right
let's just go back to none so let's just
uh
mess around a little bit let's do a trim
trim from slider
i'll trim here trim turn from slider
and what are we doing here i i'm still
just playing around with this
how do i make a cut i'm not seeing it
i guess the trim is just the beginning
and end
so okay we'll play around with that a
little bit so
the split is probably what we actually
want so i'm going to click split here
and it looks like it split wherever
i was at currently so i know said this
wasn't going to be a tutorial
and i don't plan on making it one i'm
just really curious myself so
i just kind of want to play around a
little bit and see what happens here
so click on this one move this over
go to trim trim
oh not trim split looks like it splits
it right where that is
so we can do another split over here
another one over here and now we have a
bunch of different video clips down here
so we go over to this one
that's that first clip then another one
so you can kind of section it
off it looks like and do little effects
on each of them like maybe on this one
we want a little uh
a rotate or something okay so
pretty cool i like the workflow it's not
too bad i can see how you can produce
videos pretty quickly with this
but i think we're going to kind of leave
it at this well let's just find out how
to render because i know people are
always going to ask
play around the clip all you want but
how do you get it to render so let's get
out of this
now let's go to save video here and it
looks like this is where we get the
final save and it does look like these
are
locked unless you buy it so
unfortunately we got that but you can do
all the way up to 4k it looks like
as long as you uh get the paid version
but hey we can get
720p that's not too bad for most social
media i don't think
all right so i don't know let's just
render
this render 720 and it looks like it
does have a save and a save
as so let's see kind of what the
difference is there
we get the frames per second hardware
transforms
so not entirely sure what these are
gonna do
but just based on what they're saying
there it's just some
other ways of rendering just in case the
other one doesn't work
so let's just go ahead and hit save as
and it looks like it's gonna
yeah i'm gonna go here go to rendered
and we'll just hit save
and i'm gonna pause the recording but
we're going to check out what that looks
like here in just a moment
here we're just getting to the end of
the rendering took a few minutes
and there we go so it looks like now we
can click show and folder upload
youtube share video another app or rate
the application let's just go
to show and folder and we get an access
denied
from okay i'm not going to give this app
permission at the moment so i
i'm just going to go to my folder i know
where it's at and it's just right here
that's the wrong thing
it isn't rendered and there it is
you see some of the other videos from my
channel and other random stuff
it looks like we're just going to open
it with uh well i have vm plc somewhere
should we blc or maybe i don't i don't
know whatever we'll use this
uh
i'm pretty sure i have vlc on here i'm
not sure why it doesn't show okay let's
just pop it open with this i guess
that's like a
what kind of file is this hold on let's
just look at this let's look at this a
little closer here
it's a dot mp4 okay that's pretty
standard
so yeah we'll go ahead and just open it
like i said this is a fresh
installed windows okay so it's not too
bad and that was a 52 minute video
we're going to do it pretty quick it is
only a 720p
but it looks like it's pretty decent
it's got our effects in there that's
where we just popped in a few random
things like that rotation
yeah so not bad not bad i really really
the one big complaint i have is i wish
up front they told you that like they
they told you what they pay wall
because i had no idea was paywall until
i got in here and started using it
it would have been really nice to know
that you're not going to get the render
quality
unless you uh pay i knew you had to pay
for some features but i didn't know it
was going to be for the render quality
that really hurts
because of course you can get whatever
render called quality you want with a
lot of other apps like resolve
davinci resolve but that's a huge
application that takes a lot of practice
and learning
this i don't know this is the first time
i used it i was able to pop it open and
just kind of figure it out and
yeah i could i could see being able to
do a whole fancy video pretty quickly
here a lot faster than i could do it
with resolve or
blender but uh yeah you just got to pay
for that quality so
yeah i guess that's going to be the
video thanks for checking it out
this is emoticon or wait is that how you
say it
an emoticon anna
that's going to trip me up all the time
animotica it's animotica i'm pretty sure
that's how you say it so thanks for
watching we'll see you guys in the next
video
matt from codetech tutorials over and
out peace guys
quick shout out to my patrons thanks
guys for helping support the channel
it does mean a lot alrighty peace